um i want to talk about a film that i
love i
i i i i don't know you guys showgirls
maybe you guys see jeff
it seems like it's a misunderstood movie
and why do you think that know i is
i did anything like what four or five
years ago naomi and
five six years ago in new york at the
village
and they did a a a showgirls
retrospective
and um the uh there were like a thousand
people there and it was in the gay
community
and the uh the
they had a sitting in the back row
before it began and they did the
introduction
michael mousto there was one of the guys
doing the driver so we were sitting in
the background
and i wore my i wore a black cowboy hat
like
yeah in a white shirt and then i go up
to the stage when i'm introduced
and the you know and the uh
the michael reaches back and then pulls
this thing off my back
is a sign that says reserved and it's a
very gay audience so he doesn't know
he's here he's preserved guys
but in the course of it um
with the q and a i'm the one guy as i
said
um the uh you knew all the dial
and and you said this movie
absolutely changed my life um and then
thank you and
you know i mean he was very very
impulsive in his praise
and i guys said to him i said dude you
know all the dialogue and he said yeah i
said well
it's time to get away from you know
especially a lot of gay people have
meant an awful lot to a lot of gay
people through the years a lot of people
came up to me
always whispering and said i really love
show girls you know it was a really
great movie
and then whenever you can do that
there's so many people that became such
a big hit
on dvd and all that stuff i think that's
really great
um when i saw it again
i thought i was over the top completely
over the top
both visually also dialogue-wise
um the end and then drove it into that
campy kind of area
um the uh
it's certainly not what paul and i had
in mind
to do it to drive it into that camping
kind of error
but i'm glad i did it you know
you